we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
here is a voicemail
related to
what we talked about yesterday regarding
gavin newsom i said if newsom runs for
president they will go after him for
having been married to donald trump's uh
or married yeah to donald trump's now
wife kimberly guilfoyle donald trump jr
that is and here's a caller who says
democrats got to turn that around
hi david this idea that guilfoyle dated
newsome is bad for newsome yeah i think
is a perfect example of what's wrong
with
uh messaging from democrats okay it's
bad for trump
what they could do is say
guilfoyle
is you know was dating this flaming you
know liberal that wants
uh
you know all these liberal things so
therefore it's not a problem with gaza
newsom that he was dating her it's a
problem with trump jr is he a real
conservative he's a real american is he
really someone for you or is he just
this phony that dates uh liberals uh
uh when you're not looking it's a
perfectly fine analysis but donald trump
jr at least for now isn't running for
anything and by the way
it's not an attack that would work on a
republican candidate
if donald trump jr ran for something and
then someone came out of the woodwork
and said hey you know what
um don jr
he's really a left winger he's married
to this super left kimberley guilfoyle
now nobody believes kimberly guilfoyle
is left maybe she was before but she's
clearly not now she spoke at cpac it
will go it will get no traction that's
the perfect example
of something that will go absolutely
nowhere so they will make it a problem
for gavin newsom should it be one no
probably not doesn't really make any
sense
but uh that's uh you're you're thinking
logically and this is an electorate on
the american right wing that does not
think logically we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today california
leaders
wanted inflation relief for poor seniors
and yet poor seniors are being left out
again where exactly we will talk about
it on the bonus show secondly
idaho republicans have rejected an
amendment
allowing an abortion when it is
necessary to save a woman's life so you
have a split on these
serious but relatively rare situations
you have some uh anti-choice advocates
saying
when it is necessary for the life of the
mother it's not actually an abortion
like it might look like the same
procedure it might have the same name a
tnc dnc but it is a different procedure
so there's the one side is playing the
semantic game
the other side is fighting the
amendments to allow for the exceptions
and we will talk about that on today's
bonus show and lastly the department of
justice has decided it will not
prosecute a group linked to stephen
colbert's late show
after some unlawful entry arrests
related to the trump riots why
is are those arrests not happening uh
what prosecutions rather i'm sorry and
um also
what case are the right wingers making
that this is a politically motivated
decision we will have all of it on
today's bonus show how do you get access
to the bonus show very easy you go to
joinpakman.com
and you sign up
that's it
you can use the coupon code obama
that's with an end
to get a discount off of the cost of a
membership and you will get instant
access to the bonus show
instant access to the commercial free
audio and video streams and priority
access to david pakman's show viewer
town halls
the next of which is on tuesday one week
from today tuesday july what is that 26
6 p.m eastern we will be doing the next
live town hall
we will be streaming it only on the
pacman live youtube channel this is the
other youtube channel
youtube.compacmanlive
you can watch only if you prefer but
everybody's welcome to call in and our
members on the website will get priority
access
all of it when you sign up at
joinpakman.com
we will see you on the bonus show or
otherwise back here tomorrow